I'm Yuki, and I work as the
science content manager.
I work on the videos,
exercises, and articles
in our sciences, so, biology,
chemistry, and physics.
Failure is growth, I think is
a motto I've seen upstairs,
but yeah, for me, growth mindset is really
all about embracing failure, and embracing
just trying things, even when you know
it's not gonna work the first time,
and it might not even
work the second time,
but you just keep
trying, and you might try
adapt a little bit until you feel like
you've really got it,
because you can do anything.
I, an example I might
give is in chemistry.
So, that's where my background is,
and that's arguably, my expertise.
It is my expertise.
But I wouldn't say that's something
that necessarily came that easily to me.
I think it took me a really long time
to develop good study
habits, and one thing
that was really hard for
me, from the beginning,
was like, speaking up when I needed help.
And so I learned pretty late in college,
that if I didn't get something,
really, like, even though I might
feel like I was gonna look dumb,
getting, letting a teacher or a T.A. know
right away that, "Hey, I don't get this.
"Can you explain this to me again?"
Very quickly, was important.
So, going to office hours, really being
super vocal about when
I don't know something,
so I could get help as soon as possible.
And then, also, the other
thing I figured out was
the more practice I do on something,
the better I'll get at it.
So, even if I think I know something,
if I can't actually show that on paper,
that doesn't mean anything.
So, trying to like, also,
get lots of repetition in
on things that I'm not
that confident about,
to really highlight when
I don't know things,
was something I learned
very late in college,
but was super helpful to
me once I figured that out,
not just in chemistry, but in general.